by informatics for next generation
sequencing is a hybrid training program
on by informatics launched in
collaboration between MIT University
Kolkata and Pineville neck the program
is designed for students faculty and
researchers were interested in learning
about iterative in research in life
sciences this program will start on
January 20 Wendy and will be focused on
data science skills and machine learning
methods in application to the analysis
of next-generation sequencing data in
this three-month course we will discuss
various aspects of NGS data generation
and how the field of bioinformatics has
evolved to handle such big biomedical
data the year 2020 marks 70 years since
the discovery of the structure and the
function of the DNA molecule it took
almost 50 years from the time to
sequence the first human genome but soon
after that the technology developed at
that time started evolving rapidly by
2015 the 1000 genome project or a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2018 over 100,000 whole genomes were
sequenced today there is an
ever-increasing number of genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics datasets available that
describes sub several processes with
highly detailed digital data ingest
technologies are used to explore the
rules relationships and the actions of
various types of molecules that make up
the cell of an organism many types of
omics ticket are can be generated using
NGS or what is also known as
high-throughput sequencing the data can
show the ill information about genomic
variants epigenetic regulations as well
as gene and isoform expression our first
meeting on the 13th will be an
introductory and an interactive meeting
where we will also discuss the overview
of the entire problem followed by a Q&A
session in this session we will
introduce the participants to the omics
logic resources these include the
educational portal and the big data band
from
platform developed add rubberband
traumatic stressors Center this program
will cover the analysis of gene
expression data with practical sessions
and online tutorials anyone with a basic
knowledge of cell and molecular biology
will be able to conceptually understand
as well as practically apply standard
data analysis tools to analyze process
interpret complex transcriptomics data
every participant will have a personal
dashboard where they can see their own
progress score points and get
international certification upon the
completion of the program On January
20th we will learn about next-generation
sequencing data and the need for
pre-processing
mapping and quantification to see how
these methods are used in real rnaseq
studies we will practice running such
pipelines on the demand for platform the
platform is a color-coded and has
pop-ups with the ill information about
each analysis step to help you establish
a logical connection between theoretical
aspects of data analysis methods and the
practical steps needed to achieve a
biologically interpretable result in the
next session we will be learning about
statistical analysis used to study
processed RNA seek data we will see how
exploring the gene expression table and
understanding its properties can help a
spot technical variations that can have
unwanted effect on our analysis we will
discuss how we can compare proof of
samples that represent different
conditions and learn about differential
gene expression e test and regression on
the 30th of January we will meet for a
hands-on workshop at MIT University
Kolkata there we will go through the
topics we covered in the previous
sessions and review student and faculty
PI informatics projects the next session
will be about exploratory data analysis
oftentimes statistical tests do not
capture the granularity of expression
data in a given data set to learn about
methods that can handle complexity that
is
typical for large omics data sets we
have to learn about additional methods
of dimensionality reduction data mining
and classification in the next class
will be going through data mining
techniques in this online program we
will learn about other methods including
various approaches to do clustering
network analysis that can be used to
mind rich transcriptomics data for
meaningful patterns once we learn about
these data mining techniques and explore
various patterns that seems meaningful
we can train a machine learning world
that will classify new samples into
different patterns in this part of the
program we will learn about discriminant
analysis and classification including LD
a support vector machines and decision
trees but ultimately we will try to
connect the data with biology how can
these genes isoforms or their expression
levels help explain the mechanism of
action explain the process of
deregulation of vital cellular pathways
or provide indication that a gene or a
protein can be considered as a target
for a truck for example we will learn to
utilize gene set enrichment analysis to
find pathways or genes enriched with up
or down regulated genes of interest
these methods are not always used in
small research projects however they
have important application in pharma
biotech R&D as well as clinical
applications mastering these techniques
will help you understand biomarker
discovery and patient stratification
both of which use predictive modeling
and feature selection on the 20th of
February after week we have our second
online workshop where we will review the
topics covered before and we'll also
have group presentations and discussions
on various issues research topics we
will also learn about the impact of
feature selection on interpretation of
work condition sampled from various data
sets finally we will start working on
new by informatics project starting 27th
of February
this program will include a number of
research projects you can join ranging
from biomedical to agro biological
studies students and faculty from MIT
University came up with these and
collected the data that is already ready
for analysis together we will continue
to work on thesis projects and learn
about research collaborations during
this three-month program these projects
will help you understand important
research problems and the way you can
use data analysis to derive meaningful
insights like many of our past
participants participants of pi
informatics for NGS will get an
opportunity to present their analysis in
front of their classmates and peers i'm
biotech Ben phonetics programs have been
highly recommended by our previous
participants together we are building up
an informatics community that works to
address cutting-edge research problems
using bioinformatics please find all the
important links related to this program
hello